how's goin' brows
(STFU KBOO)
LOVE BTS!!!
Who am I?
I don't even know anymore. It's been too long.
Family friendly Felix... family friendly Felix...
family-friendly Felix will graph...
family friendly Felix will rise like a phoenix.
That must be who I am, yes, it's all over
the news so it must be true!
*pewd's fav illuminati song*
Hahaha!
This song is so fucking tight.
Family-friendly Felix I love money too much. *goin' crazy*
Check out that shit.
Day by Dave, that's a good one.
That's our new intro song from now on
forever, we're keeping this for it.
He's done other ones?
(le kazoo kid vibes)
Hahahah!
What the fuck?
(le kazoo kid vibes)
Good channel :D
*le satanic undertones* *dude stop with the le's* *ok fine* LETS DO THIS! HEY LETS DO THIS!
Hahahahah!
LETS DO THIS! HEY LETS DO THIS!
lets do dis.
hahahah. -_-
That's fookin awesome.
*slows down*
OOOOOO
Wot?
O! O! O! O!
I gotta send this to Jack
Am I a Nazi? Or am I family-friendly? Which one is it? (definitely a Nazi)
I don't know anymore.. let's see what
other people have to say PewDiePie vows
to go family-friendly it looks like
popular youtuber PewDiePie is continuing
his string of 'attention-grabbing antics'
I didn't ask you to write the fucking
article.. you did you did on your own
f*cking.. you reroute his article based on
satire because you wanted to get an
article and you're calling me out for
attention. Fuck you!
Pewdiepie claims that as a
result of this new policy a third of his
videos have been demonetized cutting
into his income of four million dollars
a year so basically what happened was I
in a video a few days ago I made a joke
saying I'm gonna go family-friendly now
it was clearly a joke if you can't tell
that whenever I wear a hat like that I'm
probably not making a serious statement...
"EI WHAT IS HAPPENIN? Waddap it's your boi
PewDiePie! Big announcement, big
announcement, big announcement let's get
some excitement everyone got a big
announcement I'm going family friendly now."
So the joke is that I'm going family friendly because there's been
some advertiser repercussion on YouTube
it seems that channels that our family
friendly aren't really affected. I made
the joke, but it seemed like people don't
understand that it was a joke I mean
look at this satire or serious.. you
decide *giggles at their pathetic soul*
they know they know it's that
satire but apparently I'm just doing it
for attention and I think most of my
fans.. understand that it was a joke as
well but I did see I did see some people
not understanding as well for example
here feeling family friendly content
also Felix put that in your mouth
because you're a whore literally a few
seconds later in the same fucking video
clearly I wasn't serious about
going family friendly.. clearly I don't really
give a shit, okay.. I my videos have always
been family-friendly you're you're
getting this the wrong way as you can
tell they've always been top notch sit
down with your whole family no matter
what age and just enjoy for example such
classics as boobs boobs boobs boobs
boobs boobs boobs boobs boobs boobs
(we need more boobs!!!)
[thumbs up if you think so ;) ]
boobs I would say that the only reason
that people get confused whether I'm
actually family friendly or not it's
because these fucking article are
posting about it. since when did it
become ok, to write an article about
satire I don't understand why that
somehow acceptable it just doesn't make
sense PewDiePie vows to go
family-friendly as he suffer major
advertisement loss'. Polygon posted this
unironically and I slightly call them out
on it and then they make another tweet
saying low did we really take the bait
though and then they're quoting satire
amazing so why write the article in the
first place then especially with the
title like that if you get a report on
satire what's the fucking point it's
like saying PewDiePie states in a video
that he's gay actually it was a joke
great you just wasted everyone's time XD so
here it says in the title PewDiePie vows
to go family-friendly the first line in
the first line they say that it's a
satirical video but the problem here is
something that I keep talking about that
I keep having to pay the fucking price
for is that it doesn't say in the title
that it's a satire if you just read the
title you will think; ''oh ok so felix is
losing a bunch of money and now he's
going to find family-friendly what a
fucking asshole.'' and yeah it's bullshit
and you might say ok well they put it in
into the s-s they put it right
underneath they put it here and the
video so you can just check it out
yourself the thing is people don't read
your shitty article they just read the
title and by proving it literally the
first comment saying serves him right
but come on how long do you think it
would really last they are legit
thinking it's true even though in the
article you're saying that it's not why
because they read the title and
I'd say when your network is estimated
around 61 million as I fucking youtuber
you don't ever get to complain where was
I complaining? I get comments from other
people that I don't really know being
like ''oh so how's your family friendly
thing going?'' like for fucks sakes that
was a joke everyone is posting about it
and it's the exact same thing with all
the Nazi shit like I'm really glad that
most people looked into it but there's
still a lot of people that just read
headlines and we're like well I guess I
guess he actually is a Nazi now because
I read it somewhere I don't mean to keep
complaining about these things at the
end of the day I'm just gonna have to
accept that this is who I am and if I
make a joke saying I'm family-friendly
there's going to be articles about it
because apparently that's relevant I
know a lot of people don't like Polygon
I always thought Polygon was alright but
seeing them keep making articles like
this like reporting on satire I really
think I really think they're better than
that like if you want to be a serious
gaming website why are you making
articles like that I just don't
understand I think you're just making
yourself look stupid like have they no
shame I just don't understand these
people are they that desperate they must
be it's this so bizarre to me because
all vox media actually isn't it and
Polygon owned by box? yeah it is well I
should explain it.
PewDiePie comes out
as gay on Twitter you can't miss it
today ok apparently I'm gay now as well
it's too funny it's too funny these
fucking people post about anything let's
see what some of you guys think about
the new family-friendly Felix
[I LAVE YOU]
Meet friendly Felix he's an extrovert and
sociable guy he loves to spend quality
time with his friends and wait a minute
what's that hand movement
stop let it stop god damn it fuck
honestly I don't know why I even care
like it's not even at least we'll always
have family friendly Felix
*JAM COMES ON*
*ENDLESS JAM OMG*
my videos are 10 minutes long.
Let's say you had a normal 9-5 kind of job what
if I told you you can do the exact same
amount of effort give give out more to
the people that consume your products
and get three times the amount of
revenue would you not take it I don't
fucking think so ok don't be mad at me
we met at YouTube ok I didn't make up
these fucking stupid as rules around 10
minutes videos it's fucking stupid I
watch a lot of my older videos like from
2016 a lot of them were like four
minutes five minutes and i think that
works out fine a lot of times but a lot
of times it just feels too short having
a daily video that's just like five or
six minutes it just feels i don't know i
think 10 is the good length anyway what
do you what do you think let me know I
don't it's a lot of more effort like
it's a lot a lot of extra work to get it
to 10 minutes and still keep the same
quality and we're really trying hard to
do that every single day so stop
complaining god damn it
[WE LAVE YU POODS] [ALSO NICE JOB, EXACTLY 10 MINUTES]